[Music]
hey man you got me pretty good
Oh so what's going on a day oh just the
usual young buck just another day at the
laundromat yeah why people come in they
do their laundry we chatted up about
some of the topics of the day
that's just another day hanging at the
Met one of us going on in the barber
shop today so let's say they're having
fun over there
forget all that kid come on we got our
own assortment of colorful characters
right here nope you need some more
quarters Oh
she didn't hear me that's part of the
problem uncle Ted you know all that
noise up in here from the machines
running and it's kind of hot
loud and hot sound like my old lady
[Music]
bility waves is in there now he's Lando
Calrissian
he was Cloud City Danny Keith when I
tell you we've got it going on right
here okay Taylor I gotta tell you
something
[Music]
I got my own washer and dryer months ago
I just keep hanging out of here because
I didn't want you to feel bad
oh you didn't want me to feel bad oh god
you're watching try alright though
you're big-timing me now okay I see how
it is
Hey well you shouldn't clean your pants
ain't clean yeah you can't get a good
wash on one of them home watch it dry
Ted I'm going let's have some fun we
were you could get in one with the
launcher Carson I can push it around No
[Music]
hold down and keep keep
when you do a little tap there then you
go I'm your man you're Billy Dee
Williams yeah yeah are you doing
[Laughter]
[Music]
you